hmm steel man one of the most important
if not the most important conversation
an argumentation tactic to learn an
embody in your essence of course
emotional intelligence this is embedded
in emotional intelligence for me this is
embedded in intellectual discourse
period you have to know how to steel man
arguments all right what is that let's
start with what straw Manning is straw
Manning is the opposite of steel Manning
okay a straw man comes from literally
the origins of putting up a straw man
instead of an instead of my actual
argument okay
it's misrepresentation so a straw man
here's my argument maybe I say something
about how I think it would be important
for us to inspire a sense of global
unity okay so that's my argument inspire
a sense of global unity is me then
there's a straw man that an opponent
would create themselves and say that oh
no no no no that would hinder the global
economy I never said anything about the
global economy I just said it was
important to inspire a sense of unity
and so that in that argumentation they
created a straw man of my argument
saying that I said something about
hindering the global economy when I
didn't so in in the sense if you want to
retort to my point and bring up the
economy you would do something along
these lines you would say that hmm
inspiring a global sense of unity how do
you think that would impact the economy
there you go that's how you would do it
you would put forward the exact argument
that the person made that your steel
Manning right this is the opposite of
strong meaning your steel men you're
making the argument even better you're
showing the person that you actually
paid attention to their argument that
you actually heard understood felt what
they were saying and by doing that you
then reassure that person that they can
feel more comfortable because you
actually understood them right okay we
should inspire a sense of unity and then
the person retorts mmm a sense of unity
inspired how do you think that would
affect the global economy right so by
doing that they understood you right
they brought up your point they steel
man your point and then they asked a
question on top of it now it's difficult
how would it affect the global economy
right where would conversation go there
there's so many other examples of this
that are happening all around the world
all the time and it's been happening for
a long time it's almost like a quick way
to just get through something instead of
actually have a nuanced discourse and we
have deep rooted cognitive biases that
drive us towards this misrepresentation
because it makes it easier for us to
defeat things if someone puts out a very
nuanced and complicated argument for us
to try and remember seven different
points that they said that are all
complex from different fields that
they're synthesizing that then that it
becomes so difficult for someone to be
able to think of all those seven fields
how they synthesize that that they
usually try and do something like reduce
it to a single variable and then try and
say something about that variable that
the person didn't even mention
so we gotta remember that if someone's
laying out a complex and nuanced
argument practice retaining the most
important aspects of it even practice
writing it down like this is why I've
been parsing people speaking parsing
videos parsing conversations for key
points we all do it but we sometimes it
slips and then we strawman but if you
parse more frequently for the key points
and then you try and read paraphrase
those key points that someone said can
you really remember the seven fields
that someone synthesized into a key
point well yeah if you practice writing
them down if you practice storing them
in you as they talk through memory
techniques you can actually do a good
job at paraphrasing making someone feel
felt making them feel like they were
heard like you care about them and their
argument that they're putting forth and
then you by doing that makes them relax
more makes them feel good and then you
can then ask them another question or
then you can show them how it may be
they have some sort of a fallacy in
their logic maybe there is an error in
the way that they're piecing those
fields together but by saying those
seven fields first and how they
synthesize it and saying hey when you
brought up fields
five and six and how those connected can
you explain more about how those
connected or I think there may be a
fallacy and how you mentioned that those
connected specifically and so these are
very important ways for us to learn how
to have better conversations how to
structure discourse in a way that is not
going over each other's heads but rather
it's coming with each other's hearts
that is so important moving forward
especially as things like echo chambers
are separating us and polarizing us to
be able to really push for nuance driven
centric conversations that are
multivariate that are hard to remember
it's hard to remember 20 complex points
on healthcare but it's easy to just say
Oh healthcare is binary this way or it's
binary that way it's way harder to hold
all of the
complex facets of a health care
conversation and write them down and
have a nuanced friendly conversation
with someone about it so remember to
steal man remember that difference
between straw Manning misrepresenting
someone's argument purposely to make it
easier to defeat and the person's like I
don't even say that versus steel Manning
and call people out when they strawman
to explain to them what straw Manning is
and to help teach them and on steel
Manning to practice doing that more
often and practice sharing steel Manning
more often with more people practice
building up people's arguments
paraphrasing it synthesizing and making
them feel like they were heard and then
further after that ask him another
question about her explain to them where
maybe a fallacy was or an error and then
or even potentially bring up the
argument even more and that's the idea
of tennis so you can hit back a tennis
ball and you can help augment someone's
perspective when you do a really good
job of making them feel heard all right
guys have more conversations about steel
Manning teach people about straw Manning
teach people about the differences and
have better conversations around the
world it's so important to embody more
steel man nuanced conversations around
the world talk to your friends families
Congress people online about these
subjects and subscribe to this channel
if you haven't yet go and hit the like
button go and share it with other people
follow us across platforms help support
us so we can continue doing cool things
like interviewing the greatest minds
alive and having these little streams of
consciousness for you thank you very
much for tuning in Big Love steel man it
out